failing is never failing it's always a
learning experience I stopped living
according to what people wanted me to do
I could call it living according to what
actually made me happy independence is
priceless
it's just people that have never had it
don't even understand the motivation
watch it's often with leave nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from hustling newspapers as a kid so
that he could buy sneakers to becoming
the co-founder of Rockefeller Records
and a successful entrepreneur he's Damon
Dash and here's my take on his top 50
rules for success also if you want to
know what Damon Dash and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 250 4 days
I will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
link to join is in the description below
knowing the one thing you have to really
never do is compare yourself to other
people absolutely that's the one thing
you can't do it judge this exists to
someone else's
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get out of the nine two five nine
two fives aren't good because you look
you hustle fourth weekend but when you
do something that's for yourself and
your family it never feels like work I
hustled for my house fulfill my last
name I don't hustle for my first rule
number two be patient
I've learned over the years that you
know with anything you have to be
patient not in five years patient or
five you know five months patient you
know you could be ten years patient if
you want to you know empires aren't
built overnight you know they mean like
I always tell you by the great wall was
a 2000 year old plant mm your main life
times that is at one plant you know and
getting people to to to kind of you know
do the same have the same exact agenda
for lifetimes the generations that's
crazy so you know you have to be patient
when you want to do something
significant no matter what and a lot of
time that means you know not reaping the
benefits of something immediately
and that's the test rule number three
put your own money up I don't think my
approach on business is with the average
person would advise like most I hear
people say never put up your own money
and I'm saying put your own money up
work harder than everyone be patient and
just know that if you're gonna do
something on your own you're gonna have
to feel some pain rule number four pay
your bills you know you always have to
have something that's paying your bills
so that whatever you're creating can
breathe so you don't have to rush it you
don't have to make it push it to make
money when it's not ready you know what
I mean like you kind of always have to
have something solid and then you that's
paying your bills if you know cuz even
as an artist to me as a man you still
have the responsibility to take care of
your woman to take care of your children
and to take care of yourself and you
know almost in that order it's like
children your woman and then yourself
you know what I'm saying but all of that
should be able to be taken care if
that's a real man you know and as an
artist you can't say alright well I'm
not going to take care of my children or
take care of my woman or even take care
of myself well to protect my artistry
then that's not artistry to me that's
just being lazy you know I'm saying I
think as an artist you have to fight for
that artistry you know what I'm saying
like you have to figure out how to pay
your bills so that the artistry can
breathe you know what I mean and it also
you know that's how you feel like I'm a
real man remember five embrace pain did
you ever watch a James Bond movie where
it doesn't look like he's losing at some
point and then he wins or Batman or Iron
Man or any superhero there has to be
some diversity for you to you know
overcome to win you know it can't be a
champ unless you uh you know are in a
place where you look like you're gonna
lose and then you win the pain that's
gonna come with being independent you
have to embrace it because it's gonna
happen and also know that the more
successful you get the more problems
you're gonna have the more not you're
gonna have that time being a boss does
not mean smooth sailing it means having
the ability to care about other people
before yourself and to untie problems
untie knots that's all it is there's
it's not business if there's not problem
there's nothing good without struggle it
just doesn't happen and all my
experiences there hasn't been one thing
that's been successful without me
feeling some pain before it was
successful so now when there is pain I
embrace it you know I've been embracing
it I Maji about it because
I know that must mean that if I'm cool
that you know what awaits me tonight the
darkest before the dawn I don't I don't
want to like sound corny but that's
really what that's that's what has to
happen rule number six lay bare I'm
always gonna play fair you know what I
mean like I don't believe in doing
anything unless it's fair because I
believe there's always karmic
repercussions from doing things unfair
so what could appear to be a win or
something that appears to be a fast you
know fast money and I don't know in the
long run I'm gonna suffer but you know
it's always a test quick anything quick
as a test you know I can get it quick if
I don't have to cheat but if it you know
if I gotta cheat to get it fast I don't
want it
rule number seven be independent my
parents haven't bought me clothes since
I was about 14 my parents had me
I haven't had nobody buy me nothing
let's say that no one's taking care of
me since I was 14 years old and I didn't
want nobody taking care of me because
they couldn't what they was trying to
buy me I wasn't trying to win rule
number eight higher intentionally taste
talent and work ethic you know I mean
and all of it I need all of it you know
taste talent were catfish you know well
perspective so when I interview or my
even when my the people I work with find
more talent they have to bring me I have
to get a mixtape from them can't even
know what music they're listening to cuz
tasted music tells a lot about a person
it really does um I got to know who the
best their favorite designer is what's
the last book they read favorite artist
and it's funny that sometimes you know
you get those the answers are hilarious
but people will be trying they don't
have you know but you know you honestly
have to have your like I look for all
your senses to be activated you know I
mean like I need you have good taste in
music
I need your work ethic I need you to be
a good person I need you have a good
taste in clothes you know I need to be
you need to be able to be savvy and more
than just one thing like everyone that
my staff can do like there's not one job
that anyone does in my staff rule number
nine stop caring what others think I
make a regular business that doesn't
touch pop culture doesn't make history
than to some people that could be
considering going back
that's not a pressure for me because I
could care less what people think and I
don't think there's anything about my
career where you would think I did it
for someone else I'm just constantly
trying to impress myself like I've
accomplished you know relatively
speaking a lot of things and because of
that I've been able to do exactly what
inspires rule number ten don't be lazy
everyone has the ability to take care of
themselves you can always be a hunter
you can always eat the food you kill
it's just about how lazy you are you
know there's a theory it's all about
your effort rule number eleven do what
you love motivated not get burned out I
only do what I love you got to do what
you love you can't get burnt out and I
do get burnt out you know once I'm in a
business and I don't enjoy it no more
that's the thing I can't it's hard for
me to stand in business for a long
period of time because the people tend
to make me sick so as soon as I start to
get aggravated you know it's like I'll
be on the block if the block starts to
make me mad I go to another block even
if I got the block click and it's just
like I won't compromise my quality of
living your autumn sample like right now
what I'm doing is you know I'm building
things that I could pass to my kids but
only things that I love them and my
family so I love making movie I'll make
it movies I love it I don't think I'm
gonna be burnt out with that any time
soon you know and then also when you're
in the business of making money off
other people that person could make you
sick and you don't want to make money
off them no more so that's the reason
why I try to only make money off myself
these days and also do things that you
know my girl and my wife rocky if she's
inspired then we'll do that business I'm
like some revolving my children I like
that business but I worked hard to put
myself in that position rule number 12
make things happen
was there some pivotal moment for you in
your life where you just really got it
and and something happened a fire
ignited inside you that made it so that
you had all the moving parts to make
this amazing career unfold I think the
death of my mother probably got me
really focused and I understood that
there wasn't gonna be anyone there to
take care of me had to take care of
myself and just out of respect for her
life and all the things she did to make
me a better person I had to apply all
those things so you know at like 17 my
mother died when I was 16 or 17 you know
I was running the streets so heavy and
it was getting so critical then I put
myself in boarding school you know I
figured out how to get a scholarship
and because of the ability that my
mother gave me to articulate what's on
my mind to read to write you know cannot
be afraid and also I was you know boxing
so I got went to the boys club and they
were given our scholarship for you know
you took a test I passed the test and
you know I made it and I was just always
able to put myself in a better place I
never let anybody else control my
destiny my mom's taught me to make
things happen on my own not to depend on
anybody and if I have an opinion to
speak on it rule number 13 be consistent
the only way to be a professional is to
work harder than everybody a
professional like a professional
baseball player boxes someone that's
better than everyone else that's why he
gets paid so much to do it that means
work it ain't nothing professional going
to give in to you there's some sacrifice
there's always pain and you know it's
always gonna be dark times because
that's part of business every time you
create a new business you got to
struggle a little bit and it takes a
while to build a brand it takes about
five years to be consistent like my
first five years you know I'm not saying
nothing different I've been saying the
same exact stuff if you go look at
backstage and any kind of argument I had
it's always been consistent it's just
people weren't ready for it they didn't
trust it but after I've been saying it
for 10 years a five you know five to ten
now it's a brand I have a brand for time
consistent I back it up I'm still here
I'm still up even when you know being an
independent man looking like you was
down rule number fourteen finished the
fight failing is never failing it's
always a learning experience soldier
the thing about businesses is how deep
your pocket is I always say that like if
you got a lot of money you could sustain
these losses until they turn into gains
but if you have a short paper if your
money's not long if you don't have
enough you have to make sure that those
losses don't kill and compromise your
pocket and that's the point you got to
get creative but when you do anything to
get better at it the more you do it and
the first time you do anything you
usually don't do it correct so it's not
failure it's learning experience if you
could get up and it's like in a fight
the first round you might get knocked
out but by the last round you get up and
knock that person now won't you might
lost around but you win the whole fight
you might you gotta lose some rounds in
business but at the end of the day you
want that unanimous decision you gotta
keep going you gotta
to fight the question is do you have the
stamina to finish rule number 15 be
fearless but you get on the web and you
did check out whose Dame - and there's
so much crap how do you deal with that
and how do you suggest other people deal
with it when they reach a certain level
of celebrity I mean when you sign on to
being a certain level of celebrity you
got to know they're gonna say things and
you know things are going to get
eyeballs and get people to buy you know
it's in and you know I just I really
don't care and one of the reasons why I
think I've been successful is because I
didn't care if I cared I probably would
be too scared to promote people that
people don't want to promote you know it
takes fearlessness to be first you know
to not move with a crowd to move alone
you know and you get scrutinized by
people that do move with a crowd because
they gotta make you look bad to make
themselves look good it's all part of
the game it's like a guy that's in high
school that gets all the girls the rest
of the dudes hate him in high school so
my whole life has been being that guy in
high school that everyone hates cuz I
keep taking their girls good understand
that not a bad life so that's how I look
at it but the price of success is
unsuccessful people don't like you who
cares for us successful people don't
care about what another person is doing
cuz successful people want everybody
else does bcz exactly that's my no
that's this whole mindset that people
don't understand right so it's usually a
bunch of unsuccessful bitter bitter
people and you know I was a guy in
school that you know was got kicked out
of every school I was the class clown
you know I wasn't the guy that you would
traditionally think would be go this far
so me making it made all my teachers
look stupid every principal that kicked
me out of school look stupid you know I
went to South Kent in Connecticut on
scholarship I didn't come back the next
year the next time I came back was on a
helicopter and I landed it on the soccer
field you know that when I got kicked
out of Dwight in the seventh grade
you know my son came back and they were
asking me you know I put my son duty I
paid full tuition plus extras for
tutoring and they asked me to build a
library I'm like the same principal that
kicked me out is asking me to build a
library so it's egg on all their faces
you know my success makes a lot of
people look like they were wrong because
a lot of people articulated the fact
that I wouldn't be what I am today and
either way either way I didn't care but
I think it's kind of funny it's egg all
over
face scramble rule number 16 be a boss
is in everyone but not everyone has a
discipline for that anyone could be an
entrepreneur but not everyone wants to
be an entrepreneur some people rather
depend on other people because they feel
like they don't have to work as hard but
being at the preneur means working hard
it means embracing struggle it means
being a leader then we're never sending
somebody to do something that you
wouldn't do yourself a real boss will
never send somebody to do something with
it do themself a boss that tell somebody
to do some of the things we do is not a
boss he's a cow and I that both
principles came to me from the people I
knew in this treaty right so somebody
like rule number 17 use your money I
didn't want to do so much that every
dollar goes back into the street like I
just paid my bills and I wanna buy some
I buy it but you know I'm generally
trying to independently financed all my
all the things that inspired without
compromise so every time I pay for like
I already know I'm not holding no money
like I you know how I'm spending my
first billion i'ma buy a football team
you know saying like I have no intention
on holding any money and the only way to
get to a billion is to keep putting
money back into the companies and
flipping and I'm gonna just be flipping
my whole life you know that's just my
game was I got cash flow I'm cool you
know I don't really believe a hold of no
money I think that's for suckers
rule number 18 do new things it's hard
you do a lot and it's all relative you
know what I mean like the first time I
heard a record on the radio I was
excited the first time I saw my video on
television I was excited the first time
I saw a movie at if the optical level
was very excited you know
first times of anything are exciting and
I tend to have a lot of first times you
know what I'm saying yeah that's
absolutely incredible so I try to
recreate that first time feeling by
doing new things you know traveling the
world is important opening up art
galleries all over the world has been
fun you know opened up an art gallery in
Hong Kong was dope as well as Charleston
as well as the Lower East Side as well
as Tribeca all of those first times were
great you know I'm saying being in
different neighborhoods moving and not
being scared
to you know have growing pains and
thanks to that nature so it's all been
really fun it's been a blast
rule number 19 have a plan a business
plan get a lot of business that doesn't
exist is a lot because you can't you
can't say like who do your facts based
on because it hasn't happened yet you
can't really determine who's going by
what and how much this cost sell you
can't say I make a million this year
there's no right you know what what I'll
do is put together what I it's like a
script I put together how I make the
goods I'm gonna market the goods how
much just want us to buy the goods but
we have with my margin and then when I'm
gonna sell it and then how much I'm
gonna put back into the business and how
much I'm gonna put in my fire you know
if that kind of thing you know I write
things that like if you look the one
that look gonna put that on the wall
right there right this is you see you
see a piece of paper while I don't know
under one it that's it I got a do you
know I like to put things on the wall I
can't even know what I've got to do I
need to look at it and it cross it out I
don't consider that a business plan per
se or but I have a plan
you know I'm saying like I have a plan
plus you want other people to understand
the plan because you can't do anything
on your own so you want to be able
articulated to them away they understand
and if they could look back in because
I've talked quick and like you said a
lot of times I say [ __ ] you like I
didn't understand that
until a year later you know so you want
to have something someone makes you look
at that and they can see you crossing it
off and then they can kind of get it by
absorbing or you know by watching what
you're doing
rule number twenty serve others you know
I support the arts and I give people
platforms you know what I'm saying like
to me a real person that it is it's
supposed to be a leader is supposed to
serve the people you know what I'm
saying that's what you're supposed to do
you're not supposed to be worried about
yourself you know what I was I've been
thinking about lately
you notice that in the music business
traditionally it's the businessman
that's robbing the artists and they
always the artists ends up with the with
the behind the stories the way they now
I would add now nobody did I ever touch
a rich they'd be doing well and I'm the
one that's always looking for a while
doesn't that way it is cuz I give it all
the way I'm not trying to take the
artists happen in my pocket for his life
and jerk him and have him resent me you
know I'm saying I'm ready to get him out
my pocket be like look man go win go eat
go be yourself we'd leave me alone
rule number 21 stand out from the crowd
at a young age I remember getting yelled
at in in nursery school when I was four
or five and I felt this feeling of
embarrassment and at that moment I was
able to identify that feeling and I was
like I will never let myself feel
embarrassed again so from then on
nothing young in age yeah that I would
just you know I didn't like the feeling
I felt funny I felt like I was shrinking
like you know what Fred Flintstone gets
yelled at and you get smaller yeah I
didn't like anybody making me feel
smaller just put by the energy of their
voice so it was almost like I put this
repellent on where nothing could
embarrass me you know I'm saying so I
just never really kid and I never wanted
to be a part of a crowd I always wanted
to be an individual I hate it when
everybody looked the same so it was like
it was corny to meet it like to like
something cuz somebody else like this so
I was like that guy that was like if you
like it I'm not gonna like it you know I
always wanted to be first never be last
I never wanted to like follow a trend
I've always wanted to start it and I
think that comes from the Harlem swag
and all that and that confidence is what
made me not really care so when I would
speak about things that no one else was
speaking about if I was gonna do
something that no one else did I
embraced that loneliness you know
because it meant I was doing something
right where other people right and and
as a result of it because I would always
give 100 fearlessly and stand behind my
point of view I'll
got the reception that I thought that I
deserved which was you know being able
to have the life that I want it
rule number 22 take control again
recognize what really makes you happy if
you feel like you lose and you lose it
it doesn't matter what other people feel
so I know how it feels to be perceived
as winning and be feeling like I'm
losing I stopped living according to
what people wanted me to do I could
start living according to what actually
made me happy like if you in a situation
that don't make no sense then get out of
it don't make it make sense
one plus one always equals two if you
not happy change your life
rule number 23 be independent you got a
kid from the streets coming up and
they're trying to make you incorporate
but they don't necessarily have you're
not gonna make it incorporate right he's
gonna create his own corporate he's
gonna have to buy things like you did in
the street like a t-shirt right you're a
$5 and go sell it for twenty and the
reason why I can do a lot of it is cuz
of the internet you could do it on its
own as a Instagram or one is a website
and that's it it's a flip there's no
difference the only difference between
corporate and independence is corporate
doesn't use their own money it's always
a fun another fun and another fun that
throws into another fund then the person
that that that finds all that money gets
a fee and acts like it says you know I
mean you know the game that's corporate
yeah corporate is a facade but it's not
yours you can't give it to nobody you
can't give it to your family you know
I'm saying
a true man wants to make his life easier
for his children not himself right
so I can just have a job where I get
fired or I'm I'm done my kids don't get
it I'm a hustle for pension panel not in
the company cell I don't get nothing
what you working for if it's not chores
how hard you gonna really work for it if
you don't only think about it
you working for a paycheck you're gonna
do at least amount of work as possible
unless you really believe there's a
future in it
that's why what everyone I work with and
you can ask anybody in there as soon as
I get it in I know
the ideals and the principles if you
help me I'm gonna help you
my thing is I make people independent I
don't make them dependent so if you
notice all the people I put on they
still doing it so you've got jay-z you
got Kevin Hart you got Lee Daniels you
got Rachel Roy I didn't teach them how
to be dependent on me I taught him how
to rob I taught him how to cut the
connector
basically I'm the dumbest person in the
world if I'm for free I teach you how to
get it without me and I'm getting paid
to be the middleman so once I teach you
that you don't need a middleman you get
rid of it I'm mad at you for that that's
why I taught you because once that make
your dream come true I'm off to make my
own now I'm gonna sit around in your
pocket all day rule number 24 work hard
on your craft fight expect expect to be
uncomfortable and if you're not devoting
between eight and twelve hours a day on
your craft then you're not really trying
to be a professional like you got to
realize you trying to be competitive
being a professional means being the
best in the world
that doesn't just come with skill that
comes with discipline you know that
means you have to have a certain kind of
work ethic that means you're doing
things that most won't people really
don't understand it like they think they
got skill so everything is going to come
to them skill is actually like a curse
I've seen people with no skill that
realize that and understand that they
had to work hard to get this skill
worked so hard that they do better than
the people that have skill and that are
arrogant and entitled that feel that it
should just come to them and then they
just become a waste you know having
potential is [ __ ] if you don't
realize it it becomes corny like you're
the cool guy when you have potential but
like ten years later if you don't
realize it they need a corny guy you
know I'm saying and I never want to ever
be that guy
rule number 25 leave your comfort zone
what does it truly mean to be
independent just to be able to do
whatever I want to do whenever I feel
like it you know I understand like I
couldn't imagine like that's why I hate
his school I just ain't on and I'm not
saying people shade school but I just
couldn't stand a teacher that I didn't
think was cool or smarter than me
telling me what to do and then I had to
sit there and listen but for anybody who
actually has that fear like that wakes
up and they deal with that fear and they
go into a job and they're in between
deciding if they're just gonna go out
and be independent or not like what are
your words for them I would say blindly
do it wait and figure it out the more
uncomfortable that makes me feel the
better
cannot be great comfortable grabber
remember 26 make good products I don't
believe I should have to be nice to get
somebody to give me something if my
product is good no matter how I act you
will pay for it you know that's another
principle that I learned in the street
when people want their drugs they'll
line up but get told what to do
they'll be yelled at they'll be talked
to get in the back of the line I'm only
taking 20s don't even coming in with a
dollar that kind of thing
no one's nice today the drug dealer
don't have to be nice his work got to be
good and that applies exactly in real
business as long as your work is good
people will come when your work isn't
good you have to have gimmicks right so
in the street you got two four five
three dollar bottles and chicken bags
but usually the works not good right so
in this world when you overcompensate
when you don't have good work you
overcompensate with the tension you
start to become like you sell celebrity
that's what you leverage so now your
game becomes going outside being a slave
to what everybody else thinks
and that's another rhythm that I didn't
want to abide by as well like I wasn't
going to be about that celebrity all I
want to do is be about good product good
work be respectful make an honest living
and work with honest people and all and
the Internet has made it really possible
to do that because again you can make
your product you could promote your
product you could sell your product you
collect the data and have that
relationship directly with your consumer
rule number 27 be selfless you know one
thing Abbas has to realize is your job
isn't to take care of yourself your job
to take care of other people so that
means you have to completely be selfless
if you're selfish at all you're not a
boss if you don't have the ability to
care about other people before yourself
you're not a boss people practice being
bosses every day because they're parents
you know you care more about your child
and you care about yourself that's like
your business that's what the boss does
you know I've had to pay my staff before
I pay my own bills because they did the
work you know what I'm saying that's
what the boss does rule number 28 do it
all so people who take the leap and they
make that first they take that first
passion and build a business or they
start something but they have other
talents or other disciplines that they
want to build things around how have you
managed to build multiple companies or
take that blueprint and apply it to
different
areas and manage that it's because I
look at all the little companies as
marketing for one company when I make a
movie I got to make the movie right so I
got to do that
but also after I make the movie I got to
distribute the movie so I built the
platform like Dame their studios or
whatever app I'm a distributed you
understand then while you're watching
the movie like you gotta wear clothes I
wear clothes I like to make clothes I
have the ability to do it I was in the
fashion business still am so I make all
the clothes it's a commercial for the
clothes I like music but not in a
traditional sense I don't want to
monetize and then exploit artists but I
do have a deep catalog of music that
I've made while I was just inspired in
the moment I could use the music in the
movie so now you can sell the music you
sell in the fashion people drink right
so why won't you drink to look at it I
make I make the liquor so then now you
can you know drink to look but I'm just
saying so everything you see I feel like
I want to make because I have the
ability to do it you know what I'm
saying so I do it so I basically
leverage the things that people pay for
that's what I use for marketing so I've
always looked at looking at rock with
look at the state property when I have a
movie called state property then you got
clothing called state property you have
album called state property state
property that 20-something million and
clothes that year just because of the
commercial that the movie presents why
would I pay somebody to do something I
could do myself like well I'm gonna pay
a bodyguard when I can fight rule number
29 architect your life the thing is you
got to think about your future at all
times what do you want to look like in
10 years what is your day what do you
want your day to look like so at 35 I'm
like at 45 I'm definitely not going to
be trying to be getting up and going to
a office and running behind artists I'd
rather be sitting by the pool yeah so
then I started investing that's called
art detecting I started it didn't take
like overnight but I had to know what I
wanted and had to visualize it to make
it happy be able to also work on me like
I was sick of investing in other people
yeah making money off other people
making other people's dreams come true
and then it has to be a be fun I don't
feel like hanging around
yeah you know what I'm saying I got to
look like this you know meals whatever
we're fighting for people that just you
know the crazy thing is the more you
fight for people the more people try to
make it look like you're fighting for
the wrong reasons and I don't care what
people think so it doesn't matter but if
I'm gonna do all that I was like if I'm
a fight I'm gonna do that for me I'm
gonna do it for my family I'm gonna do
that for people that are gonna give back
see there's givers in this world and his
takers in this world so when you get
givers together it's just a love fest
you're gonna get a giver with a taker
it's a lopsided relationship and usually
the taker always feels like they deserve
more and don't give gifts and stuff you
feel what I'm saying yeah so I've been
able to heart detect it down to that
like the kind of people I want around
the way I want the body you know get but
just the intent of the people of it have
you always created your 10-year vision
is that something neither you know it
are doing yeah oh it's holy so you
always knew he liked crystallized in
your mind like exactly like where you
were gonna be ten years from where you
were yeah yeah that's cool you have any
tricks or tips that you can help again
visualize what you want yeah and work
toward it if you don't have a script
it's kind of hard to shoot the movie
yeah yeah rule number 30 learn
everything when I try to do when I start
companies is learn every single job
before we start hiring so for example
with damn dance studios I have to got
booty running game - videos and Raquel
you know editing and posting and doing
the things so that when they hire
somebody don't know what to tell you to
do I don't know how long it takes and
they'll know if that person is doing
their job and that it's more just like I
gotta work the cash register first rule
number 31 be independent
independence is priceless it's just
people that have never had it don't even
understand and I'm an expert I'm sure
you know and independence means using
putting up your own go
have to put up your honor that's
independence if someone else is putting
up the money that's dependence you
understand what I'm saying
now you gotta move when they say you
have to ask you have to be nice you have
to laugh at jokes that aren't funny you
know I mean you have to be around a
racist and let them say little things
little few things a nerd square that
wouldn't survive in the street and
independence is like being let me tell
you their perspective of something
that's independent if there's like a
wild dog he has to literally eat the
food he kills he cannot eat unless he
kills something that day and then
there's a girl that's changed lives in
the house but he has three square meals
a day he got to do tricks he gets tired
he just kicked out and gets beat you
gotta give walk he walks on a leash when
that dog comes in the room with the wild
dog wild dog is the last thing he
doesn't care that you're in a mansion he
doesn't care that you eat steak every
day he still thinks about her he knows
he can take from you because he knows he
has to kill every baby you know I mean
and that's a confidence that's a
rockstar and that's the one thing that I
know I would never give up you know the
ability to be that act like I laugh at
anyone that's a cage dog you know walk
on a leash told when to eat and those
tricks and rolls over check rule number
three to embrace pain why is it so hard
to bet on yourself for a lot of people
like what's the heart of it why why is
that so hard for people to do to put up
their own money and bet on themselves
when they see it really works out
eventually
because because
your money that's a struggle and a lot
of people don't just want to walk into a
struggle
almost like some people don't even
though they can fight they're not really
you know have the discipline to go to a
training camp and really focus and see
it through and flecked I don't want to
walk into the to the struggle to win you
have to it to wanna win it means you
have to embrace pain you have to embrace
stroke you don't know saying like you
have to know that nothing's gonna be
easy you voted to be the best at it in
the world you have to do it and push
yourself from those people want you know
what I'm saying you gotta be up for that
yeah you know what I'm saying like you
if you up for it you could do it but not
everybody's up for it not everybody
really the infant conceptually they want
it for doing what the pain it takes to
go get it and I have a lot like these
people that I like there's things about
them I don't like but I respect the fact
that they're gonna fight to get what
they want the fight and all this to
whether that our perspective is
different or not they're fightin well
every time whether it's wrong right the
person that fights the hardest plants
you really ultimately know that if you
really believe in yourself and you work
hard at it you'll achieve it the
question is am I ready to work so hard
that I'm better than everyone else you
understand what I'm saying and you have
to answer that question within yourself
am I ready to embrace all the pain that
nobody else wants to embrace yeah am I
ready to really work harder and do it so
much that I'm better at it than everyone
that does it it's really about the work
ethic really it's a professional work
ethic you can't just be good at
something you have to be able not to see
things too and do the things that you
don't enjoy it's not really about the
things that you enjoy that's the easy
part it's the things you don't enjoy
that's the things that people usually
shut down about they just don't like it
it's just because you don't like
something doesn't
failure rule number 33 be the plug not
the customer what I do is I'm a
businessman right in any business the
more crowded it is the harder it is to
do it so I never want to hustle on the
crowded block so regardless to what I'm
always looking to do something that
nobody's doing so all I was looking at
was what's the next wave logically it
was just logically I was paying
attention you know what I'm saying so
once I realized I'm like I said I met
this freedom was ridiculous and plus
like it was like damn if I know how to
make this myself
like content is like currency it's the
thing that makes money forever and ever
it's over it looks like it's like when
somebody smokes a joint the weed is
going you got to grow more weed when
somebody looks at something you can pay
over and over again to see it and you
ain't got to keep making it I just look
at what people pay for and do it myself
I'm the plug I'm never a customer do it
yourself and leverage your own celebrity
right so instead of letting somebody
else make it we make it and then we
don't have to pay for the marketing it's
easy so now that I'm a brand for doing
that I can now completely invest in
myself but there's two games one is
making good work and one is leveraging
celebrity right the good work Dwayne
gotta move good work they find you you
ain't got to promote your destination
when you ain't doing so good that's when
there's the overcompensation you start
have red carpets every day and do
another to distract the fact that you
have no talent you can say I wanna marry
number 34 be confident confidence and
not giving up is the it makes you so
lean like the don't give a factor that
makes it way you don't care what people
think you never feel like you're being
judged you never want to be a part of a
crowd and you just you know you just
feel this about the way you feel about
things you know and then also you got
swag you know you just you just do what
you want regardless of what people think
and it feels good
rule number 35 find real wealth you know
what's time initially when you when
you're brand new to independence
my state is honestly it's a tough - what
you value as wealth right like if you
value
and your happiness is ultimate wealth or
if you value perception and physical
things is important that wealth do you
dig on like physical things is temporary
so you go hustle for the temporary yeah
well you gotta help hustle for the
forever yes all this absolutely you
don't want to catch that up you know I'm
saying except for everything for
physical you know I mean I think that's
the ultimate test it's like yo you're
gonna really be wealthy I mean are you
gonna be happy are you gonna look at
heroes then I'm gonna worry about how
people see you and buying physical
things that make you look better than
you are what do you really want to
really feel good rule number 36 be
obsessed with your craft how do you want
to make money
I just know this is what I do right take
yourself to five years where do you want
to be in five years
see the thing about it is to shoot a
movie you need a script right you can't
just restyle it you can't say I want to
say this or kind of like that you got to
be very direct and then you put all your
energy to what you want you visualize it
and then it has to happen I'm a
filmmaker so I'm gonna make movies yeah
I want to make I mean I've done that but
I want to do it to where I don't have to
worry about a regular job yeah this is
the way I would do it so I would make as
many short films as I can just so people
can start seeing that you're good I
would star in the movie if I want to be
anyone in this short film like a real
artist is someone that's damn near
obsessed with it like a painter should
be painting eight hours a day but a band
should be rehearsing eight hours a day
if you're a business man you should be
doing your business eight hours a day so
if you're focused on something and
you're doing it eight hours a day then
you're doing it at a professional level
but you got to know what you focused on
and then you can take things into your
own control it doesn't happen overnight
it's not easy expect pain expect anxiety
expect everything to go wrong and just
be cool breathe easy and then just see
it out because a lot of people start but
don't finish when things don't happen
the way it's never gonna happen the way
you want it to happen ever and if it
does do not trust it it's the devil rule
number 37 do positive things so many
amazing talented performers that came
out of New York in the late 80s and
jeez Mary Jay Vicky jay-z and give her a
big part of that
did you realize other time how big that
movement was going to be and then what
it was going to mean for the rest of the
world the rest of the music scene yeah I
did I did you could feel that at the
time yeah every I knew that that's why I
was the person that was documenting
everything because I knew everything I
was doing in that moment was legendary
for the way I would look at it would be
like damn could you imagine if you had
Jimi Hendrix and David Bowie and John
Lennon before they cracked or Mick
Jagger in like a studio or just kicking
it before they got famous and then
imagine when they did so because I was
so confident in everything I was doing
and all the people around me I knew that
what we were doing would probably set
the stage for history you know saying I
didn't think anybody was cooler than us
and I knew it actually and you know
turned out I was right you know in all
them I'm from Harlem he had a crew
called the best out and we said those
parties and at the Cotton Club yeah I
kicked a pre DJ and we used to make
t-shirts and we had our names on them
we've got basketball games and a lot of
people tried to do what we were doing we
were emulate it like I remember when we
were throwing our basketball games would
be like us the best outbursts kept
child's crew they would call boss and it
was crazy at the Gaucho gym and then the
next thing I would see puff do a
basketball thing but you know it ended
up being tragic but I knew that he was
influenced by what we was doing so I've
always seen how my influence has been on
the rest of the world from day one and
it still is like that people still you
know take what I do and they're
influenced by it that's why I think at
this point my life at 46 it's important
to do things that are positive so people
can emulate what I'm doing there
emulating something positive like eating
healthy like taking care of yourself but
being good to women and taking care of
your woman being a good dad like loving
your children like to me that's altima
wealth
rule number 38 be loyal and respectful
she's not convenient if you only can
this be loyal when it's like easy for me
like if there's a bag of money what you
got to do the wrong thing to beat this
little somebody we will get a lot of
want my friends yeah you know I mean and
just you know so sometimes but you know
respect to me guide you and protect you
from everything if you if you leave with
respect on anything the right things
will happen
you understand I've never seen respect
put anyone in arms way I've only seen
respect they've always always protect
you and then also the ultimate test is
always like to disrespect the people you
love to get something physical like some
play you understand what I'm saying
that's a test run I mean and tests
aren't meant to be easy you know like
that's what my test was always be able
to be like I'm I don't play one culture
and I won't get that down you understand
I just couldn't do it
my family has made it sound as I'm sure
you could have play the ball in Chatham
all the time you know that was my
problem with the music business because
it was such a such a disloyalty on my
culture to exploit it the way it was
being exploited and letting other
cultures explain it in that same and
being like aside just cuz I'm making
money
just cuz I'm alright mix it up you know
cuz I I fought through it it still
didn't make it alright to just sit there
watch them all the rest of the culture
to me that's probably sport you know it
was like guilt with it always you know
it means you're being around people I
didn't want to be around
rule number 39 approach things
differently but people make me the
underdog it's funny because they don't
understand what the game I'm playing
just cuz I'm not playing your game what
just cuz I'm not moving at the pace you
moving
they don't mean I'm wrong you know I'm
saying you already the same when it's
mine and it's never been like what I've
always like what someone thought of
record via was dull I was like a lay
with you
if you ever late you my have a TV show
Network you know that they have both
thoughts I'm always thinking of all
sports this I don't know any other
language but boss Boston you know and
say so when people don't talk in Boston
me I don't know they say you know I'm
saying it's a language it's a process
language it's like like people are
posting like bosses and people approach
things like for this a lot of people
don't want to be Boston because it's so
much just want to go in there come with
it you are saying they scared of it and
I always say that you understand what
I'm saying
what but boss only can think about it in
force terms so if someone says they want
to get in business some people might say
well I need somebody to give me a job
that's not a 4-story right a horse's if
I'm getting my four days if I'm gonna
get in business I'm gonna create the
business the business but I'm not trying
to be hired my approach is always going
to be bossy you know someone that's not
used to being the boss your thought
process ain't boss we don't have lost
cause fluent boss you know say what I'm
saying around here before winning boss
and if you don't talk to me and boss I
don't understand what I'm saying
I'm not celebrating that that you got
your lost dog is like I speak that yeah
let's be that lame you should tell what
somebody else told balls just by the
other folks one thing and someone that
talks boys doesn't speak any other
language only talk balls
rule number forty put family first
the minute I had daughters I was like I
got us changed everything I can't do
anything to a girl that I don't want
another man to do to my daughter that
was a real turning point yeah
the daughters for sure my daughter's
changed my life in my arm second or the
Cholula was born I decided to quit
everything to make sure that anything I
did I put her first not not the business
she before I was like business first cuz
I got to pay for the kids but it's like
if you're not there to spend the money
with your kids it really doesn't matter
they need you and your company so and
and I saw all the things I was missing
so you know we think I'd rather do be on
a yacht pouring champagne or a girl at
taking my daughter to get a cupcake
it's nothing better than taking your
daughter to get a cupcake you know
there's nothing better than watching
your baby smile you know so it's true
but I it's like seems obvious but you
know lotto is really like energy it's
love it's not like physical money which
really doesn't mean anything it's just
how good you make someone feel it's how
good your woman feels how good your
children feel like you have as much
money as you know billions of dollars
but if you want happy and you're lonely
you broke
if your kids are unhappy you broke you
know if your woman is unhappy you broke
rule number 41 do what makes you happy
it's all about effort and what you could
visualize in your mind you know if you
can't think it can happen and if you
don't have confidence that it's going to
happen it ain't gonna happen
so if you doubt yourself like you know
our box or at least I used to
I'm not getting in a ring unless I know
I'm gonna win or else I already lost and
I look at everything I do like that I'm
winning and there is nothing it's 100
percent everything is about perspective
and what you consider a win you know
some people think they're winning
because other people think they're
winning even though they don't feel good
about what they're doing they're like oh
you think I'm winning so that must mean
I'm winning but I feel like that's not
winning you know you have to know what
makes you happy what you consider aware
not everybody's win is the same you know
I'm saying but people like to fit in
with aw
I mean I know what my w's are rule
number 42 be the boss the reason why
people take jobs is because they got to
pay their bills when you say be a boss
to be independent everybody should be an
entrepreneur it's everyone has an
apartment right you're the boss in your
apartment right no matter what no matter
how little it is if it's whether it's a
big house or a little house that space
right there you have the boss that's
what your business is that's what your
life is you create the space so you can
control it you control your environment
but you have to art detect that you want
to live in the house build it you know
I'm saying am I gonna give it to you but
once you get in that house I don't care
if the President or whoever it is
anyway he walk in my house Obama you
still gotta listen to me in this house
people think it's safe to have a job but
if somebody can find you how is that
safe period like you got to be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you and if they the people that can
fire you don't be owned enable maybe
supervisors so then it becomes like
political if there's no politics with
you in the boss it's my way or no way
because I believe that you see that at
any point no matter how much you
contribute that whole thing can be taken
away at any particular time
right so how does somebody then go and
just make that shift to the same scripts
they're doing for somebody else do it
for yourself right if you got paid
editor edit your own movie you a paid
writer right it's home magazine you know
it's like the thing is nobody ever gave
me anything no one gave me real no
record deal I had to do it myself so
imagine if I were to waited for a deal
for jay-z did B know jay-z there be no
Kanye there be no Lee Daniels there be
no Kevin Hart there'd be no Rachel boy
none of that you know I'm saying none of
them any I had to build all that like no
one's gonna hire me to direct you know I
mean no one's gonna hire me to beat of a
CEO of a company I made the company I'm
the CEO of it period rule number 43
believe in yourself what I find is a lot
of people have really insecure about
themselves they don't think there is
interesting as they are so many people
be so quick to make money of other
people's experience I mean you know when
you got your own like what's the purpose
today there's no say that again yeah and
that's what I had to do that's what you
had to do are once we started to believe
in ourselves we just work a little
harder but you end up reaping all the
benefits on it on your own terms and it
feels 100% good and you catch all the
people you own and it makes the most
sense
rule number 44 love the game I wanted to
capitalize
capitalize off everything I thought I
was the best
so I thought I was the best at dressing
I didn't think I could dance better than
me so I thought new records I knew I had
the best more authentic experiences so I
know I make the best movies and I just
wanted to do all those things but in
hindsight I just like to do cuz I like
to do [ __ ] it's fun I'm really creative
you know what I mean I just like to be
artistic freely and you know it's like I
don't know I just I just I just like
don't I just thought you know I think I
just I'm having so much fun and you know
when you get success relatively young
it's like you know get settled but then
you go get bored so you know I was a
mogul when I was in my 20s so I was like
I want to go do fashion I want to go I
want to run around the world I wanted
everything I see or hear about I want to
see it personally I want to live it I
want to know what I want to touch it
rule number 45 invest in yourself so
looking back that how do you feel about
Rockefeller today it doesn't same
attitude that I think it's a shame it
doesn't exist anymore you know I think
the way that it dissolved was kind of
selfish but I'm not gonna get into that
you know I'm saying but it would have
been nice to see everybody doing well as
opposed to one person and that's the way
I want it Rockefeller I'm a you know I
believe in the circle of success where
everybody gets rich I don't want to make
employees I want to make bosses well it
was you know but then it turned out to
be one person stayed rich and everyone
else had to work for him and that's not
how I looked at Rockefeller and what I
realized is I need to make an invest in
things that I could pass to my family so
I had to invest more in myself as
opposed to investing in other people
because not everybody has the same idea
idea idea a lot of ideology as me you
know I'm saying not everybody you know
looks at things the same way so you know
I should have probably paid a little
more attention than making assets that I
owned as opposed to making other people
because my thing was I was putting
people in power so that they could put
us in power but every time I put
somebody in power they would shut the
door and they just wanted all the power
it's just human nature is how men are is
the testosterone and that's why I also
surround myself more with women because
men women don't tend to be so jealous do
you think that's more of an exclusively
male thing than females on as the hungry
when they get in that position I think
males are so supremely insecure that
they turn into clowns
rule number 46 don't cut corners a lot
of people would she
cut corners but I don't consider that a
win you know what I'm saying like if I
know the game I'm playing and I saw
going to it that's the only way I want
to win at it I don't want to cheat to
get there if then I didn't win at my
game I actually lost you actually lost
on exam but you know I'm not gonna play
your game I only play when we cheat we
you don't fully believe in your
abilities in the first place
yeah it's overcoming city official mood
but then that's like a different kind of
wing you know you're playing a different
game
rule number 47 dream bigger you know I
have bigger dreams than trying to be
getting a salary from some company you
know I need to own something and I
needed legacy you know like the dashes
are gonna be they are I already know
what we're gonna be like the Kennedys
and and the Van de PUE no we're gonna be
an upstanding family yeah that's what I
wanted to be that's what I mean but
that's what I'm saying I wanted it easy
for my kids and I want to easy for my
kids kids and that's all I'm doing right
now we're just making sure that the
company could run when I'm not around
you know I'm saying family and company
that's what that's what you know it has
to be able to sustain rule number 48
don't operate out of fear everybody says
they want to be the boss but people who
stand to be the boss most people are
scared to put up their own money most
people are scared to tell people to work
when they don't want to most people are
scared to even ask for the money you
know what I'm saying like people I've
seen people that are uncomfortable about
asking about their own business like
asking for change get paid or when am I
gonna get paid or where's my money I
have never felt uncomfortable about
asking for my bread and I've never
understood people that were
uncomfortable for asking for their bread
and I really don't understand people
that are offended by you asking for your
bread yeah you ask somebody
they're like what you asking like I'm
not supposed to ask my money am I
supposed to ask about my money like the
money and the business this motion with
asking about it because it's business
there should be no fear you should never
be ashamed to ask for your change ever
you know or to scrutinize a bill
rule number 49 stay ahead of the curve
after my daughters were born I shut down
everything I was doing I bested all my
money into at Rachel Roy and then I just
opened up art galleries where creative
people could come in coexist and make
things happen without compromise the
quality of living so I opened up didi
172 which was a 10,000 square foot
gallery in the most expensive real
estate in Manhattan and Tribeca and you
know I had people like most def and Jay
Electronica and Wiz Khalifa and currency
and it just goes on rock and roll the
Black Keys you know the Holy Ghost
Erykah Badu or performing I had and in
that television station called creative
control this was in 2009
I'm always added occur you want to know
the future just asthma and rule number
50 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is attack your bucket list we
have chapters in I like this you know
the cool about the way I post thing is I
always have like an ill bucket list you
know I'm saying and there'll be there's
a bunch of things that I want to do in
my life and eventually I don't know imma
do it so young I wanted to hustle I got
that off my bucket list quick you
understand I wanted to be a music mogul
off my bucket list I wanted to be a
fashion mogul off my bucket list I want
this soil or
my bucket list I want that art galleries
off my bucket list and the things that
were like all my bucket list but things
like I'd be like even though you saw it
in the book one day I'm gonna do a
diabetes Network I'm gonna do something
that's just about that beans I did it
yeah it's all [ __ ] this you
understand what I'm saying
one of the things on my bucket list is
the owner football team one of my things
on my bucket list is to have a network
you know a real channel to have a hotel
so there's always like a chapter of my
life where I attack that bucket list one
of the things are not bucket list is to
dwell lay it you understand what I'm
saying and to be able to have a farm I
will try to grow cotton make the clothes
in the car and the driver that's what
we're trying to do in North Carolina
now I've got a bonus special clip from
Damon - on how to play the game right
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that except for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what's
the biggest thing on your bucket list
that you want to attack number two how
would you do it if you weren't operating
out of fear and number three how would
you do it if you dreamed even bigger
people that think that the only way you
can make it especially in our business
the entertainment industry that you know
you can't be an honorable honest
hard-working person you've got to be
willing to do whatever it takes
regardless of how you compromise your
own ethics to get to wherever it is you
want to get and I've never believed that
and it doesn't sound like you believe it
either no you know I don't consider that
a win I consider that cheating and I
can't live with myself if I don't play
the game right but other people don't
like to go into different cultures and
especially in business it's like yo you
got to win any way you can if somebody's
slipping and you don't take advantage of
it you're dishonouring your family like
I've been in cultures like that mm-hmm
you know we're lying is okay for your
business you know you're supposed to do
that or else you're a sucker so you know
it's just a matter of perspective and
the cloth you're cut from and you know
it's a rougher world when everyone is
cheating and you're playing the game
right you know it's a tough world but at
the end of the day it's worth it because
you know there's nothing more valuable
than your soul your integrity your
freedom you know just being proud of
yourself I just don't feel like you know
when you you can't call yourself a
winner if you're cheating you know
you're a cheater you know I just how I
feel and you might not get caught in the
human form but God will get you you
think I forgot or whatever the supreme
being is if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon if you want to learn how
to become your own boss like diamond -
check out the video I made right next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there people
think it's safe to have a job but if
somebody can find you how is that safe
period like you got to be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you